It's how,
how comfortable is it when it gets in through their ears?
Yeah.
Like is it getting an easy or is it like,
oh,
this guy's on?
No,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll,
I'll bring on a guest,
I'll hear the guest say something and I just cringe because I anticipate the
comments and it's like,
dude,
you're about to get crushed by the weight of the world.
Will you?
Well,
you quiet somebody.
No,
I mean if I have to,
uh,
try not to,
if I have to correct them,
like if they're saying something that I know to be inaccurate,
if it's in my wheelhouse,
like sometimes people say something and I'll just say that's not,
that's not true.
Here's why that's not true.
You know,
I've had people say some goofy shit and it just happens to be something I know a
lot about and then I have to stop it.
Yeah.
Okay.
That makes,
that makes sense.
Cause,
but for the most part,
I want people to just be themselves.
I got to figure out how to get you to be yourself.
That's what a lot of this is comfortable make you realize that.
I just want you to do great.
I want everybody to do great.
Are you ever intimidated by gas?
Yeah.
By their intellect.
Like Elon Musk was intimidating talking to him cause you realize what a champ
you are.
Oh yeah,
I'm a fucking dummy man.
But like talking to this guy,
I'm like,
I'm a fucking chimp.
Here's a question.
You just kind of like a champ.
I got to go to Mars.
Huh?
Cool wants smokes weed.
Yeah.
A cut of that.
Like your Chin is motherfuckers making electric cars,
you know,
sending rockets into space.
He's drilling holes under the ground.
You had to dumb them down with Megan solar cities.
We didn't even,
didn't even work,
but so here's my take on it.
Right.
I'm watching Musk.
And he basically is opening up to you about how he's not happy.
Yeah,
right.
There's this moment where he's like,
I think he said something to spend of you one want to be me.
Yeah.
You said this was his exact words.
He wouldn't want to be mean.
You wouldn't want to be me.
So that means he doesn't want to be him.
I think on some level he doesn't want to be him.
Right?
Yeah.
And
he's so with these guys that we admire because they're so brilliant and they
have all these brilliant ideas and we're,
we're putting this matrix of we're all in this success matrix on some level,
right.
Where it's like get things done good.
Don't they can get things on bad.
Right.
I wonder if
if he's chimp ish in that he's potentially wasting his life being upset or
miserable when he could be focusing on things that would give them joy.
I just,
that being a is that being a fucking chimp is being so smart that you don't even
try to just be happy and focus on your happiness.
I don't necessarily think he's unhappy,
but I do think that he puts himself into situations where the amount of stress
that he absorbs is almost unfathomable.
Like when he was trying to get the Tesla model three production re scheduled
ramped up and he was sleeping on the floor of the factory and working literally
working like 1920 hours a day.
That that's untenable.
You can only do that for short periods of time.
Right.
But I think that what I was saying about Kanye West's applies to him tenfold.
He's,
he's got a power output that's extraordinarily different than the average
person.
And that's one of the things he was talking about when he was young.
I mean you could probably put him on some sort of a,
I don't know what the super genius spectrum is like,
like what is,
you know what's,
what's Albert Einstein,
right?
What's,
what's this guy?
What's that guy?
He's in there somewhere.
Crazy realm of the way your brain works.
Like I think the brains are like all other body parts.
Some people born with little tiny dicks and some people got giant hogs and
that's just a fact.
And I think that has a giant hot of a brain
and it just works better.
It just,
it just is operating on a level that you and I can't,
we can't comprehend.
But I never invented a God damn thing in my life.
But I'm driving around in Elon Musk's car,
you know that motherfucker made a car and that's like some shitty does on the
side.
You know his car thing is like after he invented paypal and,
and he's,
by the way,
while he's doing the car,
he shoot rockets into space and drilling holes into the ground.
He's trying to move traffic on ground,
trying to fuck it.
He's making so are cities like he's,
he's hooking up Australia with these massive solar panel power battery plants.
Fucking fix their energy needs.
He's,
he's on another level.
No doubt.
On another level it's a different thing,
but so is he happy jail?
I don't know.
And that's a nice guy that was hanging around with him.
He seems happy.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
there was,
what is happy,
right?
Is it,
is he happy in bursts when,
well,
I guarantee you when I saw him and he was shooting his fucking flame thrower and
my,
my four,
Yay.
He was happy.
You're four.
Yay.
Yeah.
Right out here,
man.
Right out here.
He had a fucking flame thrower.
He was tapping that bitch when he walked into the door.
He's unboxing it in the middle of this hallway out here.
Yeah.
Got Flames.
There's a picture of him standing in front of the Freak party sign blown flames
out.
15 freely.
Fucking guy's a maniac.
Look at the smile on his face.
You can't tell him he's not happy,
Bro.
Look at that smile.
He's happy as fuck.
It's cause he's a kid,
man.
Yeah.
We're in a lot of ways.
There's this,
there's this fucking guy,
I forget his name is doctor a wrap,
a pie or something like that.
He's like,
it's French consulting.
He's like some fucking genius and he's like decoded cultures,
right?
And uh,
every culture echoed in he people
hire him to consult.
Right.
And like America's code is a,
it's a,
the verb is to do and the time is now.
Right.
And we're just kids at the end of the day.
It's like everything.
We love big tits in America.
Right.
Most popular plastic surgery is big tits and like France,
most popular project surgeries,
getting tits for reduced,
right.
Everything about them is like precision and like the food on the plate,
they're most popular plastics.
That's what I was talking to my buddy,
and that's what he said and mean.
Maybe it's changed to like lips or something more common now,
but maybe the one that you have to go under or dark one.
Don't fuck with your lips,
ladies.
I like it when they get a little lips.
If they haven't.